[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the goblet of fire
the weasley family and jk rowling
more specifically we're going to be
dressing a gaping hole in the goblet of
fire plot
that jk rowling was able to rectify by
removing
a certain unknown weasley family member
there are nine immediate family members
of the weasleys to which were introduced
in the series
in no particular order we have ron
charlie
ginny molly fred george percy
arthur and bill the weasleys first make
their mark
right near the beginning of the
philosopher's stone when harry stumbles
into them
at platform nine and three quarters
almost immediately
we get the sense that harry is going to
be close with these solid
kind people and over the course of the
books films
harry basically becomes family where
harry was shunted the dursley residence
which is ironic since he is actually
related to them
he was conversely welcomed with open
arms at the weasley residence
however interestingly enough originally
there was actually supposed to be
another weasley child
that came to prominence in the books
films
jk rowling discusses this in an
interview
the first three books my plan never
failed me
but i should have put that plot under a
microscope i wrote what i thought was
half the book
and ack huge gaping hole in the middle
of the plot
i missed my deadline by two months and
the whole profile of the books got so
much higher since the third book
there was an edge of external pressure
and what exactly was that gaping hole
all about
i had to pull a character there you go
the phantom character of harry
potter she was a weasley cousin she
served the same function
that rita skeeter now serves rita was
always going to be in the book
but i built her up because i needed a
kind of conduit
for information outside the school
originally
this girl fulfilled this purpose though
not
a direct child of molly and arthur the
unknown weasley was in fact
a cousin miffalder weasley the daughter
of the
second cousin who's a stockbroker
mentioned in the philosopher's stone
mafulda however would turn out to be the
most unpleasant child mrs weasley had
ever met
and she would prove to continually butt
heads with the protagonists
mafalda was supposed to convey certain
information about the death eaters to
harry
ron and hermione because as a nosey
eavesdropping slytherin who likes to
impress
she does not keep her mouth shut when
she overhears their sons and daughters
talking
but rowling ended up taking her out
because she felt that the character was
out of place
unfortunately however bright i made her
there were obvious limitations to what
an 11 year old closeted at school i
could discover
whereas rita skeeter whom i subsequently
built up to fulfill
mufold's function was much more flexible
did you guys know about this unknown
weasley had you
heard of her before comment down below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe
to the channel until next time it does
not do
to dwell on dreams and forgets to live
you